اخبار الحرب على غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه
اهلا بكم السلطات الصحيه في غزه تعلن
استشهاد 207 فلسطينيين واصابه اكثر من 300
جراء 15 مجزره ارتكبتها قوات الاحتلال
ووسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تعلن ارتفاع عدد
من اعتقلهم الاحتلال من اهالي غزه بنسبه
150% وتقول انهم يع رضون للتنكيل في معتقل
سري بصحراء
النقب جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يعلن اصابه
31 جنديا في معارك غزه خلال ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه وكتائب القسام تقول ان مقاتليها
اشتبكوا مع قوه اسرائيليه راجله من النقطه
صفر واجهزت عليها شرق مخيم البريج وسرايا
القدس تعلن استهداف دبابه ميركافا بالمخيم
والمجلس الامني المصغر ومجلس الحرب يعقدان
اجتماعات لبحث الترتيبات الاسرائيليه لما
بعد الحرب الى الضفه الغربيه حيث استشهد
اربعه فلسطينيين برصاص الاحتلال شرق
قلقيليه واعتقل 26 فلسطينيا من قبل قوات
الاحتلال في مدن وبلدات فلسطينيه مختلفه
والاحتلال يجرف اراضي واشجار زيتون في بيت
صفافه بمدينه
القدس حزب الله يقول انه اوقع قتلى وجرحى
في استهداف تجمع لقوات اسرائيليه بكنه
زرعيت الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن قصف مواقع
وبنى تحتيه تابعه للحزب ومحيط بلدات عده
جنوبيه لبنان ووسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
تتحدث عن سقوط مسيره اطلقت من لبنان دون
وقوع اصابات الى اللقاء
ah